brigitte lahaie une cassette qui sort de
goût qui s'appelle anthologie du plaisir
tu pas mal mais c'est une caissette qui
retrace les meilleurs extraits des films
x que j'ai tourné entre 76 et 80 ouais
et c'est vrai que j'aime bien cette
cassette c'est bien la dernière fois
qu'on vous avez à la télé c'était chez
pivot
oui enfin les derniers points importants
oui très important rythme bouquin c'est
un rendu très bien dans ce genre en
livre de poche mais faut les armer
mission g alors on apprenait dans ce
bouquin vous avez connu votre première
jouissance en faisant du vélo sur une
scène de vélo c'est c'est vrai ça c'est
une invention tout ce qui est vrai j'ai
fait des mensonges par omission mais
j'ai fait je n'ai aucun mensonge il n'y
a pas de mensonge
tout est vrai il ya un truc est très
honnête aussi dans le livre c'est à dire
que finalement vous de faire l'amour
devant une caméra ça vous excite plutôt
que vous faites pas comme certaines qui
disent moi je suis comédienne tout ça je
fais ça pour gagner ma vie mais bon
c'est vrai j'ai pris j'ai pris beaucoup
de plaisir à faire ces films et jeux
renée uriage pour vous reconnaissez dans
le bouquin que vous êtes un peu
exceptionnel est un peu brutalement
conscience n'est pas de jouer la libye
culturel où elle élit comédienne quoi je
crois qu'il allait vie culturelle en
ayant plus des films x aurait été très
difficile à jouer
de toute façon non c'est s étaient
incités par plaisir que je joue j'ai
j'en ai marre j'ai arrêté et j'ai fait
autre chose dont vous cachez pas dès mai
telle est sa demande et j'aime beaucoup
d'érotisme ouais vous dites vous dis
dans le coeur vous dit que vous avez
participé d'ailleurs à des partouzes au
roi rené ad oui à la bonne époque comme
on dit ouais c'est vrai entre jusqu'à
enregistrant 80 c'est vrai qu'un jour il
ya une star de la chanson et du cinéma
qui est venu qui s'est fait sans mec
comme ça c'est tout à fait vrai mais il
ya pas mal de gens comme nous qui vont
me
en fait c'est leur vie privée donc on
reste trop et vous pouvez passer des
landes
non non juste rétablir au plus vite un
truc dans le livre qui est assez dingue
que je savais pas c'est que le sperme
des mayas pas tout le temps le même
moule c'est vrai les notes du sud et du
salé les femmes non plus ouais donc ça
veut dire quoi jeudi à la transpiration
n'a pas le même goût
ça va depuis sucrée ou salée si je peux
dire passant par les pisse et enfin way
que ça vous dit que c'est une chose a
expliqué aux femmes parce que si des
fois un jour elles en ont goûté
inquiétez pas c'était avant très lourd
en plus jamais en beauté alors c'est sûr
on leur explique que ça peut avoir un
goût différent finalement c'est vrai ça
peut être très bon cette question de moi
je n'aime pas les plus tôt sucre est ce
vous avez un palais plutôt salée ces
questions ne vous dit que vous êtes
clitoridienne mais que vous n'êtes pas
lesbienne vous n'aimez pas ça non c'est
pas incompatibles et dans les films par
contre c'est quand même bien fait d
scène de lesbianisme oui c'est donc pour
ça que je peux dire je n'aime pas ça ça
me plaisait pas c'est un peu comme si
vous écoutez moi j'aime bien les hommes
ouais quand j'aime bien les hommes qui
pour front des choses que les femmes
sont rares mais enfin les hommes aiment
bien faire ça aussi qu'on aimerait mais
quand vous et c'est avec une fille dans
un filtre pour ça me gêne pas mais ça
vous gêne et ça ça vous dégoûtez pas je
vais faire du tout je n'ai jamais fait
de choses qui me d'éviter les plus
pauvres alors vous dites aussi un truc
que je savais pas du tout c'est que les
filles qui font de la sodomie dans les
ils porno on les met un petit peu à part
comment ça se fait c'est pourquoi cet
ostracisme et fassent beaucoup de choses
et je crois que c'est parce que j'ai dû
dire du vouloir vivre c'est que les
filles qui font uniquement ce ça
s'appelle doublé comédienne qui refuse
de faire bon elles ont un côté comme ça
je suis presque comme les cascadeurs
donc c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
qu'avec cascadeuse du film porno c'est
ça vite que c'est souvent des filles qui
se défoncent
des concerts rock c'est vrai qu'il
aborde mais vous les mettez un peu dans
la même
même catégorie mais je crois je crois
que de toute façon il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se droguent ses tournages là
vous n'avez jamais été en contact
moi c'est pas mon truc de rebelles même
pas fumer un joint
je suis même pas de cigarettes sont bien
nés pendant que des défis 180 en 81 81
c'étaient les petites écolières de
frédéric en sac
et bien alors depuis grâce à canal+
devenu beaucoup plus tard à l'époque les
banques se passaient dans du sable kc-x
non c'est surtout grâce à la vidéo vue
puisque depuis 80 les vidéos il dessine
se vendent surtout en vidéo le
spectateur dans pratiquement plus en
salle et par contre les vidéos seront
très très bien que vous faites alors
maintenant bah écoutez j'ai tourné un
film
policiers avec des scènes très fort qui
sort le 15 juin avec le boël umberger
comme partenaire comment il est
maintenant à écouter il est bien
conservé ah oui tout à fait c'est un
homme de 40 ans voilà ouais t'es
toujours son regard inquiétant
et puis il est très agréable c'est vrai
tu commences tu sais c'est pas les
prédateurs de la nuit et se sent le
piège s'est réalisée par qui geste
rencontre j'espère que le produit par
owni château est alors maintenant est ce
que vous allez faire comme les sportifs
une fois qu'ils ont quitté le
sport blanches des lignes de vêtements
ou est-ce que vous allez parrainant le
seul projet dans ce style là c'est de
partir de septembre je dirige une
collection de l'ouvrir aux tic chez
hachette
voilà et donc je suis en train en ce
moment dans leurs énormes aimant bon
donc je vois déjà vos biens de choses
vous les envoyer voilà tout à fait
fondée en voyez je vais sorte choisir
les meilleurs si on fait comment cette
production une bougie cas est présente
carrément comme gérante est bilingue
c'est vrai vous en sortez bien alors ça
va oui ils ont cofinancé par d'autres
films derrière mais aux celtics et de
même boulot ou à l'époque du car il est
devenu par exemple que dit mme décarie
est le travail le travail que du dessous
je crois que dans une ferme avec des
animaux elle a même complètement
bon allez passez vos fils je crois pas
non moi je suis via bordeaux
qu'est ce que je sais pas dernièrement
je crois qu'elle est et qu'elle était
elle travaille dans une galerie d'art
dont elle rassure jean dans le domaine
artistique
si je puis dire mais je sais pas
exactement j'avoue que nie tout contact
depuis jamais de regret d'avoir fait ça
non je n'ai jamais jamais cru parce que
rien de manier civile et à devenir
comédienne et c'est grâce à ça que j'ai
découvert mon
l'allemand du cinéma
le plaisir d'être devant une caméra il y
est celle actuellement pour les
émissions télé lui est celle d'être
choisi la voie la plus facile voulait
non je voulais je voulais devenir
quelqu'un ouais je veux pas être la
femme de quelqu'un je voulais devenir
quelqu'un je voulais être un individu
bon peut-être que je plonge je crois que
j'ai choisi la voie la plus difficile
voilà pourquoi c'est pas la voie la plus
facile vous êtes mariés non non vous
avez quelqu'un je j'ai lui
comment il salue l'arrivée que c'est
pour un dîner chez des gens quand je
disparais continue
et brigitte lahaie commençait toujours
fort note pour un homme d'avoir une
femme qui fait beaucoup de choses et
nakiele achetez-vous devient traçage
bien c'est certainement très rebelle
horizons promis je serai là je pense
qu'il est ravi et très flatté
j'aurais tout cas je pense qu'il y aura
des scènes j'atteins les corrections de
ne rien rater de l'ina l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus